suis allé aux premières auditions du
procès j'ai trouvé vraiment que le monde
finalement était formé de gens
merveilleux et de jean ignoble en fait
vous ne savez pas comment votre fils est
mort vous devez enquêter sur tout et
vous confronter ils étaient ni sur la
liste des morts ni sur la bbc insu
réalité hopitalisés il était nulle part
est ce qu'on peut vivre malgré cette
douleur quand j'ai écrit à la fois je
souffrais parce que ça me rappelait des
beaux souvenirs avec stéphane en même
temps c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
l'union européenne financera pas de
barbelés de murs aux frontières douze
états membres réclament la construction
de clôtures pour empêcher les arrivées
de migrants la présidente de la
commission ursula von der leyen leur
oppose une fin de non recevoir
les 27 dirigeants de l'ue étaient réunis
ces deux derniers jours en sommet à
bruxelles
[Musique]
et c'est donc depuis bruxelles
qu'emmanuel macro un des fondus
l'indemnité inflation de 100 euros
mesures annoncées hier soit par jean
castex alors que flambent les prix de
l'énergie l'opposition souhaite une
baisse des taxes sur le prix des
carburants pour le chef de l'état cette
aide de 100 euros est juste et ciblée 40
millions de français sont concernés
face à l'explosion du nombre de cas de
contamination et de décès fléau qu'ovide
vladimir poutine décrète une semaine
chômé la russie vient de battre un
nouveau record
1064 décès en 24 heures dans la capitale
moscou services entreprises et commerces
non essentiels seront fermés à compter
du 28 octobre
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france
c'était le dernier sommet européen
dongala merkel la chancelière allemande
ovationné par ses homologues pour
l'occasion ils ont loué sa sagesse
angela merkel qui a plaidé pour le
dialogue avec la pologne ce sujet et qui
s'est invitée dans les échanges entre
les 27 dirigeants de l'ue eux il a
également été question de la crise mais
de la crise migratoire point sur lequel
la présidente de la commission s'est
montrée ferme lieu ne financera pas de
barbelés et murs anti migrants aux
frontières comme le réclame douze pays
dont l'autriche la hongrie la lituanie
ou encore la pologne je vous propose
d'écouter ursula von der leyen
ya un financement de la gestion des
frontières par le budget européen est
bien sûr pas seulement l'équipement ou
en partie le personnel mais aussi tout
l'électronique qui est nécessaire et ce
que l'on appelle l'infrastructure est en
effet il y a eu une discussion sur ce
qu'on appelle l'infrastructure physique
et j'ai été très clair sur le fait qu'il
y a un discours de longue date au sein
de la commission et avec le parlement
européen qu'il n'y aura pas de
financement de fils barbelés de murs
en évoquer la crise d'un polonaise
l'indépendance de la justice et la
primauté du droit européen au coeur des
discussions
statu quo entre varsovie et bruxelles à
l'issue du sommet chacun a campé sur ses
positions lieu bloquant les fonds
destinés à la pologne dans le cadre du
plan de relance le regard de nicolas à
mirkovic analyste politique on voit mes
problèmes majeurs qui existent quand
l'union européenne fonction l'économie
globalement va bien beaucoup de pays
notamment des pays de l'est ce qui
ressemble beaucoup d'argent qui ont reçu
beaucoup d'argent de l'union européenne
ne disent rien mais dès qu'il ya des
situations de crise on l'a vu que
l'union européenne a complètement loupé
il faut le dire la gestion de la crise
du coc vide on voit qu une crise
économique majeure en europe en ce
moment avec une inflation qui arrive est
bien quand ces tensions arrivé que des
pays se soit la pologne ce soit la
hongrie que ce soit la somme unis
décident de deux candidats de prendre
les choses en main sur des certains
domaines particulier eh bien on voit que
bruxelles attaque tout de suite en
exemple vous ne pouvez pas décider c'est
le droit européen qui prime et la
question qu'on doit se poser c'est si le
droit européen prime à quoi servent les
parlements nationaux un sommet européen
aussi pour tenter de trouver des
solutions face à la crise énergétique
après des heures de négociations les
vingt-sept sont parvenus à un accord il
demande à la commission d'examiner le
fonctionnement du marché du gaz et
d'électricité pour en identifier les
potentiels effets pervers en france jean
castex a annoncé hier la mise en place
d'une indemnité de 100 euros à
destination de ceux qui gagnent moins de
2000 euros net par mois à l'opposition
souhaitait une baisse des taxes sur le
prix du carburant depuis bruxelles
emmanuel macron leur art lui a répondu
il défendant une mesure juste et ciblées
j'attire l'attention quand même de
toutes celles et ceux qui propose de
baisser les taxes sur le carburant la
première chose c'est que manipuler la
tva n'est pas possible en droit européen
la deuxième chose c'est que les taxes
sur les carburants nous sommes à peu
près dans la moyenne européenne mais ça
coûte beaucoup beaucoup plus cher et
donc tout ce qu'ils appellent la sagesse
en termes de finances publiques seraient
bien inspirés de regarder combien coûte
cette baisse
troisième élément elle est absolument
non ciblés c'est à dire que quand vous
baisser la fiscalité sur les carburants
laquelle n'augmente pas avec le prix à l
etat indéterminée c'est la tva qui va
augmenter avec le prix quand vous la
bessée vous la bc pour tout le monde
donc je considère que c'est plus juste
et mieux cibler ce qu'a décidé le
gouvernement ils ont raison si on veut
accompagner sur le pouvoir d'achat des
gens qui sont soumis à des augmentations
sur différents segments mieux vaut avoir
un instrument plus ciblée qu'un
instrument général alors que pensent les
français de cette indemnité enfle à sion
nous vous avons posé la question
c'est à part un petit peu dérisoire pour
des qui sont dans le besoin qui sont un
petit peu en situation de précarité
petit l'état pourrait faire un effort
sur la réduction des taxes ça me
paraîtrait plus
nos impôts pour notre argent pour nous
leur donner ce serait plus judicieux
d'aller prendre dans les bénéfices de
total et des pétroliers le seuil a été
tissée à des libéraux de vous imaginer
quelqu'un qu'il gagne 2500 euros 2010
euros
expulsé ted et cette indemnité de 100
euros concernera également les étudiants
boursiers et ce fiscalement autonome
délégué national du syndicat étudiant
uni rémi paiera dénonce une mesurette on
remarque encore que le gouvernement ne
règle le problème des étudiants et de la
précarité étudiante avec des mesurettes
on le voit on l'a vu pendant la crise
sanitaire on a vu pendant les
confinements successifs qui avait une
sorte
d'incompréhension de la précarité pour
les étudiants et même de mépris de la
part du gouvernement alors que nous ce
qu'on demande ce que lui ni demande
depuis des années ce sont des réformes
structurelles sur le système de bourse
parce que actuellement le stand de
bourse ne concerne absolument pas les
classes moyennes par exemple qui
souffrent de plus en plus on a aussi
demandé la mise en place d'un ticket de
restauration étudiants sur le même
modèle que celui des salariés le sénat
l'a adopté à une large majorité et le
gouvernement s'est refusé à l'appliquer
elle mettre en place
ces derniers jours donc on voit bien que
le gouvernement
ne se sert d'eux se sert de la précarité
d'une amp pour faire des effets
d'annoncé mais pas pour faire des
réformes structurelles de fond alors
conseil d'état rejette leur conte des
syndicats demandant la suspension du
nouveau calcul de l'allocation chômage
il est entré en vigueur le 1er octobre
est la plus haute juridiction
administrative le valide donc elle
estime que la tendance générale du
marché de l'emploi ne constitue plus un
obstacle à la mise en place de la
réforme le conseil d'état devra
toutefois encore tranché sur le fond
c'est-à-dire sur le mode de calcul de
l'indemnité chômage que les syndicats
jugent injuste pour les demandeurs
d'emploi
la sncf annonce qu'elle fera circuler
demain huit tgv atlantique sur dix une
amélioration pour cette ligne perturber
les conducteurs de ces tgv sont appelés
à la grève jusqu'à lundi midi les
négociations menées pendant plusieurs
jours entre syndicats et direction n'ont
pas permis de l'éviter syndicats qui
dénoncent un manque d'effectifs
un refus de congés et demandent une
revalorisation salariale sur lesquelles
les voyageurs étaient plutôt
compréhensifs aujourd'hui goûter
c'est la meilleure façon pour eux de
faire bouger les choses et d'embêter
tout le monde ils ont bien raison rendu
la situation en france est très très
médiocre je dirais donc je pense que les
grèves sont légitimes pour le week-end
oui ça va avoir
des forcément d'avoir une influence mais
c'est pas grave je soutiens les
grévistes il ya toujours un truc c'est
vraiment le bordel quoi là c'est
peut-être qu'ils s'arrangent nul quoi
en allemagne une manifestation à berlin
en faveur de l'environnement à dix jours
du lancement de la coop 26 la
mobilisation pour le climat se poursuit
donc des centaines de manifestants ont
défilé au pied de la porte de
brandebourg go aujourd'hui toujours le
même objectif amener les dirigeants du
monde à agir face à la crise climatique
mondial
bien sûr avec le fdp les verts et le spd
ils ne peuvent pas maintenant se
concentrer sur le climat ils doivent
trouver des compromis d'une manière ou
d'une autre et c'est un peu décevant
quand on sait que notre avenir n'existe
tout simplement pas si nous ne faisons
pas quelque chose pour le climat
maintenant
j'espère qu'on se débarrasse rapidement
du charbon et que ça sera menée à bien
que le fdp ne l'empêchera pas j'espère
simplement que les verts deviendront
très fort et que le changement
climatique sera bien main et appliqué
nous avons de l'électricité verte à
moitié prix depuis 2010 est cependant
les partis n'ont en général pas compris
cela et il est urgent de l'introduire
dans les négociations de coalition comme
je les dis nous avons besoin d'une
protection climatique sans fram car elle
est déjà rentable toute façon
elle a commis dix neuf continue de faire
des ravages en russie nouveau record
quotidien
1064 morts en 24 heures à les autorités
décrètent une semaine chômé au niveau
national et un confinement partiel pour
moscou les précisions de notre
correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
c'est officiel vladimir poutine a
décrété une période chômée en russie à
partir du 30 octobre au 7 novembre les
régions où la situation est la plus
compliquée pour ont instauré des mesures
restrictives plutôt à partir du 23
octobre est prolongé leur confinement
après le 7 novembre selon le porte
parole du kremlin dmitri peskov il est
impossible pour l'instant de prévoir
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
est donc délicat de prédire quelles
seront les restrictions nécessaires
après la fin de la période chômée je
vous propose d'écouter
nous vaccinons lentement qu'un certain
nombre de pays européens
moins de gens sont vaccinés et à mesure
que de nouvelles souches plus agressive
apparaissent le nombre de personnes
malades augmente c'est la réalité de la
situation à laquelle nous faisons face
mais en même temps les médecins ont déjà
développé des méthodes des protocoles de
traitement le nombre de lits a été
augmentée on a mieux organiser la
logistique nécessaire il s'agit surtout
de la fourniture d'oxygène etc on a une
grande réserve d'équipements de
protection individuelle et d'autres
types de matériaux et d'équipements un
immense travail a été réalisé dans ce
domaine le problème qui se pose en ce
moment est celui de la conscience des
citoyens
[Musique]
je parle de la trajectoire de la
pandémie dans notre pays étant donné le
trop faible niveau de vaccination de la
population
moscou est le principal foyer épidémique
est selon le maire de la capitale
sergueï sobianine la ville devrait
atteindre les pics historiques de
contamination au qu'ovide dans les
prochains jours les prévu de fermer du
30 octobre au 7 novembre les restaurants
les salles de sport les centres
commerciaux les salons de beauté ou
encore les cinémas les magasins
d'alimentation et les pharmacies
continueront toutefois à fonctionner
selon dennis protsenko médecin chef de
l'hôpital comme monarque a le plus grand
hôpital russe chargé du traitement du
colza virus la semaine chaud mais le
seul moyen de freiner l'épidémie veut le
taux encore assez faible de personnes
vaccinées à peine 48 millions et en
bénéficier d'une vaccination complète
sur une population de plus de 144
millions d'habitants écoutez maintenant
une pause est indispensable il n'y a pas
d'alternative ici soit tout le monde va
se faire vacciner en masse soit on
commence à tomber malade tout aussi
massivement et à développer notre propre
immunité si on prend la seconde option
tout sera moins prévisible et
contrôlables que si on prend la première
dans le cadre du système de santé de
notre pays il est impossible de faire en
sorte qu absolument tous les lits
disponibles soient destinés aux maladies
infectieuses
il y aura encore et encore de telles
jours fériés jusqu'à ce que nous
développions une immunité collective
jusqu'à ce que nous commencions à
utiliser notre tête et à respecter les
gens qui nous entourent porter des
masques dans les lieux publics ne pas
venir au travail avec des symptômes
d'infection respiratoire virale aiguë
nous avons déjà perdu trop de temps ne
voit encore des contaminations
aujourd'hui en russie près de trente
sept mille cas de corona virus détecté
dans le pays dont plus de 8000 à moscow
le nombre de décès a de nouveau franchi
le cap de 1000 personnes s'élève en ce
vendredi à 1064 et des nouvelles mesures
qui divise les moscovites écoutez sa
réaction
si cela est nécessaire pour améliorer
l'état de santé des gens en général pour
qu'il n'attrape pas la maladie mon avis
est positif oui bien sûr nous ressentons
un certain inconfort car de nombreux
établissements seront fermés pour les
moscovites et les visiteurs de la ville
mais en tout cas si cela est nécessaire
si cela aide les gens nous considérons
ce confinement positivement
personnellement je pense que cette
tendance ne sert à personne il semble
que davantage de problèmes soient dues
aux mesures prises contre le couronnais
virus co couronnais virus lui-même mais
ce n'est que mon opinion personnelle
[Musique]
d'un côté cette mesure est nécessaire
car elle permet de sauver les gens face
à la pandémie de l'autre la situation
sera très difficile pour ceux qui ne
travaillent pas dans le service public
pour ceux qui sont employés dans le
secteur privé ces personnes se
retrouveront sans emploi sans revenus
supplémentaires
si le confinement ne dure qu'une semaine
c'est mieux pour les enfants de se
reposer à la maison
autre record cette fois ci du côté de
l'australie à melbourne depuis mars 2020
les habitants de la deuxième ville du
pays ont passé plus de 260 jours
enfermés chez eux le 6ème confinement a
pris fin ce vendredi média ski fis
après 262 jours enfermés chez eux depuis
le début de la pandémie les cinq
millions d'habitants de melbourne
retrouvent enfin leur liberté
on se sent si bien nous avons fait le
compte à rebours depuis le début du
confinement c'est comme si nous avions
littéralement retenu notre souffle
pendant des jours des semaines des mois
la vaccination change la donne bien sûr
et nous savons que cette fois nous
allons ouvrir est resté ouvert
l'heure est à la célébration
avec 70% des personnes éligibles
entièrement vacciner à melbourne est
dans l'état de victoria le gouvernement
a décidé de mettre fin au 6e confinement
si les restaurants les bars ou encore
les salons de coiffure peuvent rouvrir
les magasins restent fermés jusqu'à ce
que 80% de la population soient
doublement vacciner et les habitants ne
peuvent toujours pas quitter la ville
pas de quoi gâcher la fête pour la
plupart des maîtres bourgne 1 qui
retrouve enfin une vie sociale rendre
visite à la famille et aux amis y est
tout simplement fantastique ça fait
tellement longtemps qu'on n'a pas pu
faire ça comme je n'ai pas pu faire ce
que je fais d'habitude pendant super
longtemps c'est complètement fou d'être
de retour aujourd'hui et c'est une
journée ensoleillée donc c'est parfait
melbourne doit maintenant redorer son
image cette année la ville a été le
théâtre de manifestations d'envergure
contre les mesures restrictives imposées
par l'exécutif dont la politique zéro co
vide a été jugée liberticide par
beaucoup ce qui lui a fait perdre son
titre de la ville la plus agréable à
vivre d'australie beaucoup d'habitants
ont d'ailleurs fui la ville pour
rejoindre la campagne une tendance
nouvelle provoquée par les confinements
dans de nombreuses capitales du globe et
nos landes l'australie la nouvelle
zélande est toujours en confinées chez
elles visent à l'objectif de 90 % de
vacciner pour mettre fin aux
restrictions
actuellement 68 % de la population un
schéma vaccinal complet écoutez la
première ministre du pays
nous avons examiné toutes les preuves
parler à des experts étudié des modèles
pour notre situation est fixé un
objectif de 90 % de vaccination complète
pour chaque district de nouvelle zélande
thp englund la crainte est que le delta
est rendu très difficile le maintien de
notre stratégie d'élimination que ses
tentacules et atteint nos communautés et
qu'il soit difficile de s'en défaire
même en utilisant les meilleures mesures
de santé publique et les restrictions
les plus sévères dont nous disposions
un nouvel épisode dont l' escalade des
tensions entre pékin et washington joe
biden s'est déclaré prêt à défendre
militairement taiwan en cas d' attaques
de la chine le président américain
affirme avoir un engagement à défendre
lille que pékin considère comme une de
ses provinces pékin qui n'a pas manqué
de réagir ce vendredi appelant à la
prudence
sur les questions liées à ses intérêts
fondamentaux comme sa souveraineté son
intégrité territoriale la chine ne
laissera aucune place au compromis
personne ne doit sous-estimer la
détermination inébranlable la volonté la
forte capacité du peuple chinois à
défendre sa souveraineté son intégrité
territoriale ne vous opposez pas aux 1
milliard 400 millions de chinois
aux états unis la date du 22 octobre est
consacrée à la lutte contre les
violences policières pour la 26e édition
des associations ont organisé des
rassemblements dans le pays au-delà du
mouvement black l'animateur la question
des violences policières continue
d'alimenter l'actualité et les débats
politiques
la correspondance à washington de thomas
bonnin la question des violences
policières est un sujet récurrent est
particulièrement inflammable aux états
unis au delà de la très médiatisée
affaire georges floyd il y à une réalité
qui est très certainement sous-estimé
une récente étude affirme que les
statistiques officielles en matière de
morts engendrés par la police est très
nettement inférieur à la réalité selon
les données de cette étude entre 1980 et
2000 18 30 mille huit cents personnes
seraient mortes suite à des violences
policières alors que les statistiques
officielles elle ne relève qu'à peine la
moitié comme le montre notre analyse la
violence mortelle de la police et les
grandes disparités raciales dans cette
violence sont restées largement
inchangées ou ont augmenté depuis 1990
alors cette étude a des relents
politiques puisque ses auteurs se disent
par exemple favorable aux coupes
budgétaires engagées dans les services
de police de plusieurs grandes villes
américaines define the police c'est
d'ailleurs un slogan récurrent au sein
du mit black like the matters alors que
pour d'autres justement ce sont ces
réductions budgétaires qui ont conduit à
une augmentation du nombre de crimes aux
états unis le sujet est donc éminemment
politique avec toujours cette fracture
entre démocrates et républicains
et il faut d'ailleurs se souvenir du
clip de campagne publié l'an passé par
les équipes de joe biden et de camara
mais les promesses du candidat byden se
sont heurtés à la réalité politique du
congrès américain faute d'accord le
projet de réforme de la police n'a pas
abouti démocrates et républicains se
rejetant là de manière regrettable les
sénateurs républicains ont rejeté deux
modestes réforme que même l'ancien
président avait soutenu tout en refusant
d'agir sur des points clés que même les
forces de l'ordre étaient prêtes à
discuter le crime va continuer
d'augmenter pendant que la sécurité
diminue et plus d'officiers de police
vont quitter leur poste parce que mes
partenaires de négociation ont quitté la
table plus d'un an après les larges
manifestations dans le cadre du
mouvement black live matters les
militants restent donc à pleinement
mobilisée pour tenter d'influencer la
politique menée par joe biden mais faute
de consensus le locataire de la maison
blanche a une marge de manoeuvre très
faible sur cette question avec le risque
de décevoir une partie de son électorat
on part au bénin où l'assemblée
nationale vote la légalisation de
l'avortement auparavant interdits sauf
circonstances exceptionnelles une loi
qui pourrait sauver des vies chaque
année plusieurs centaines de béninoises
meurt des suites de complications liées
à des avortements clandestins mathilde
euros magnan
c'est l'une des rares nations africaines
à passer le pas
les députés béninois ont adopté hier une
loi permettant aux femmes d'avorter
jusqu'à 12 semaines de grossesse pour le
ministre de la santé il s'agissait d'une
question de santé publique
selon les chiffres du gouvernement près
de 200 femmes meurent chaque année au
bénin des suites de complications d'un
avortement plusieurs familles continuent
de pleurer la perte d'un enfant d'une
épouse d'une mère partie tragiquement à
la suite d'un avortement compliqué ses
blessures sont irréparables pourtant on
peut bien éviter ce drame qui se joue
sous nos yeux jusqu'à présent
l'avortement était interdite sauf en cas
de viol de relations incestueuses ou de
danger pour la vie de la mère le texte a
été adopté après un débat houleux au
sein de l'assemblée certains députés ont
même quitté la salle
de leur côté les associations de défense
des droits des femmes se réjouissent
ne soyons pas hypocrites regardons les
choses en face
laissons-le émotions de côté et soyons
réalistes même le médecin à des moments
donnés est obligée de choisir entre la
vie de la mère ou de l'enfant et je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait sur cette terre
même dans nos familles les plus
traditionalistes des gens qui disent des
écoutes et sacrifier la mer et ramené
mon enfant mais dans un pays où la
religion est très présente la mesure
divise la société dans un communiqué la
conférence épiscopale affirme que la
législation de l'avortement est je cite
la culture de la mort
1 direction maintenant la tunisie la
concentration des pouvoirs entre les
mains du président sayed inquiète l'ue
et les eurodéputés ont voté à une large
majorité une résolution il appelle un
retour à la normale du fonctionnement
des institutions à commencer par la
réouverture de l'assemblée tunisienne le
point avec notre correspondant à tunis
bassam chebbi
534 pour 45 contre 106 abstentions la
résolution du parlement européen sur
l'évolution de la situation en tunisie a
été adopté les eurodéputés se sont
entendus pour appeler la tunisie un
dialogue national seule issue possible
sur le e pour en finir avec la crise
politique et institutionnelle composé de
plusieurs clauses ce texte met l'accent
sur la réouverture de l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple gelé par le
président sayed le 25 juillet est
dernier et l'importance du respect de
l'état de droit le parlement européen a
déclaré que la base de toute coopération
était fondée sur le respect de la
démocratie et des droits de l'homme tout
en appelant l'union européenne et ses
états membres à rester engagés en
tunisie pour promouvoir le développement
économique les investissements et le
progrès social les eurodéputés n'ont pas
hésité à rappeler à tunis que tout
soutien financier dépendrait du
rétablissement des travaux
parlementaires un message clairement
adressé au président sayed qui malgré la
nomination d'un nouveau gouvernement
demeure le réel détenteur du pouvoir
exécutif en vertu des mesures
exceptionnelles est décrété le 22
septembre dernier en tunisie société
civile et classe politique sont divisés
entre indignation devant cet acte
d'ingérence caractérisée et nécessités
économiques d'un dialogue avec l'union
européenne écouter
les relations de la tunisie avec ses
partenaires que ce soit l'union
européenne où les autres pays amis et
frères doivent être basées sur un
respect mutuel sans ingérence dans nos
affaires internes cela signifie que
personne n'a nous imposer de conditions
ou à s'immiscer dans nos décisions
souveraines mais par la même logique
dans la relation de voisinage avec ces
pays
il y a un minimum de clarté à avoir dans
les échanges d'autant plus que la
tunisie est également tenu de montrer à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur l'étendue
de son respect pour les principes
démocratiques et de son adhésion à ces
mêmes principes
en terme de danger qui menace l'union
européenne en termes d'intérêt de la
tunisie liées à l'union européenne comme
en terme de défense des principes
démocratiques
je considère cette résolution comme
normal et comme tous les tunisiens j'ai
lu le communiqué publié par le parlement
européen
et c'est la manière dont les choses sont
présentées qui pose problème cette
résolution donne l'impression que
l'union européenne nous donne des ordres
au lieu de nous faire des suggestions et
cela la tunisie ne peut l'accepter pas
plus qu'un autre pays l'union européenne
elle-même n'accepterai jamais que nous
adoptions la même attitude envers elle
moi je pense qu'il ya des soucis partagé
par rapport entre l'europe et la tunisie
et plusieurs d'entre nous moi j'en fais
partie également qui demande à ce qu'il
ya une feuille de route claire à ce que
le retour à la aux institutions soit
fait le plus rapidement possible et
qu'on met les questions d'ordre
économique et social au coeur de notre
débat moi je pense que d'un point de vue
diplomatique ce quelque chose qui était
assez prévisible qui est peut-être
constituer la base d'une nouvelle
discussion avec nos amis européens
et bah je comprend parfois certaines
réticences de certaines personnes mais
dans les affaires internationales ça se
passe souvent comme ça pour la prochaine
phase ya lieu de discuter avec nos amis
européens le contenu de cette
déclaration et comment on peut préserver
nos intérêts sont pour autant toucher à
la souveraineté de de la tunisie ni de
leurs européenne qu'elle soit perçue
comme une forme d'ingérence ou une
simple condition sinequanone coopération
bilatérale cette résolution résonne
comme un ultimatum adressé au président
tunisien le locataire du palais de
carthage a annoncé le lancement d'un
dialogue national sans pour autant
donner plus de détails sur la manière
dont il entend dissiper les inquiétudes
de la classe politique tunisienne et des
partenaires européens et c'est la fin de
cette édition se retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et
d'aider des gens ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
ils étaient ni sur la liste des morts